good evening Theresa May has confirmed
that the brexit deal will mean Britain
having to leave the European single
market the Prime Minister made that
clear a shin unlined the government's
plans ahead of the negotiation with the
EU which will begin once article 50 is
invoked in March she also revealed that
the final deal agreed between the EU and
the UK will be voted on by both houses
of parliament that news helps boost the
pound after losing nearly a fifth of its
value against the dollar since the
referendum it rebounded strongly today
and is currently on course to enjoy his
best day against the greenback since
2008 and that was despite the
confirmation that a hard brexit is now
most definitely on the cards as a
priority we will pursue a bold and
ambitious free trade agreement with the
European Union this agreement should
allow for the freest possible trade in
goods and services between Britain and
the EU member states it should give
British companies the maximum freedom to
trade with and operate within European
markets and let European businesses do
the same in Britain but I want to be
clear what I am proposing cannot mean
membership of the single market Mrs May
wasn't quite so emphatic however when it
came to her plans for the customs union
now I want Britain to be able to
negotiate its own trade agreements but i
also want tariff free trade with europe
and cross-border trade there to be as
frictionless as possible that means i do
not want Britain to be part of the
common commercial policy and I do not
want us to be bound by the common
external tariff these are the elements
of the customs union that prevent us
from striking our own comprehensive
trade agreements with other countries
but i do want us to have a customs
agreement with the EU whether that means
we must reach a completely new customs
agreement become an associate member of
the customs union in some way or remain
a signatory to some elements of it I
hold no preconceived position I have an
open mind on how we do it it is not the
means that matter but the ends
well let's have a look at some of the
business reaction to mrs. may speech the
cbi tweeted ruling out single market
membership has reduced options for
maintaining Barry free trading between
the UK and the EU my corsa chief
executive of the society of motor
manufacturers and traders tweeted the
prime minister acknowledged the
importance of single market arrangement
sorts of automotive getting beneficial
free trade agreement and customs union
critical but an immense challenge and
the chief executive the manufacturers
organization the eef said in the end
it's the detail of the final agreement
that will matter and it is important
that this will be open to parliamentary
scrutiny Parliament and business will
want to see a very clear evidence based
plan to ensure the UK economy avoid
collateral damage arising from our
departure well the property developer
Richert Isis the co-chairman of leave
means leave he's in our central London
studio and the former city minister Lord
my nurses were here with me he described
last June's referendum as the saddest
day of his business career rule mine is
let me start with you and Theresa May
essentially wiping the slate clean here
is that a good time it's a bit like an
incoming CEO issuing the profits warning
and putting out the base case before
saying things will get better from her
well I think she's sent out a baseline
for negotiation and much of this we knew
already she's been very very clear that
control of migration is important that
sovereignty is non-negotiable and that
we would no longer be subject to the
judgments of the European Court of
Justice so she's reaffirmed that she's
raised doubts around members with a
customs union quite frankly it's
pie-in-the-sky we cannot remain a member
of the customs union on the conditions
that she spelt out she set out an
extraordinarily tighter demanding
timetable I'm not sure there are many
people who believe it could all be done
within two years and she said that
Parliament is going to have a final vote
on this what is Parliament actually
going to have to vote on and what if
Parliament says no okay Richard tice let
me take up some of those points with you
there is a lot of concerns and there
that EU leaders are going to regard what
Mrs May says as cherry-picking she's
trying to cherry-pick the best bits of
the single market in customs union no I
don't think so at all I think
been crystal clear we're leaving the
single market as lord- has just
clarified effectively we're in it we're
going to leave the customs union we're
not cherry picking at all we bait the
Prime Minister is quite rightly said
we're going to have a new relationship
with the European Union a positive one a
friendly one that can work in the
interests of everybody but it's just a
different relationship and the world
moves forward you know nothing stays the
same we shouldn't be embarrassed about
that we should embrace it she gave me I
think a very strong positive speech she
embraced everything that we at leave
means leave have been campaigning for
she used our strap line that no deal is
better than a bad deal and that's
absolutely right and to pick up Lord
miners point about the parliamentary
vote if in the extraordinary situation
they were to say no we don't agree with
the deal that's negotiated then fine we
just revert to WTO rules but what is
crystal clear is two years after serving
article 50 we're leaving the European
Union and the sooner the better well
Richard you mentioned the WTO rules this
is something that JP Morgan's market
strategist has said this afternoon to
his clients taken us a whole we did not
believe the No Deal WTO option as
credible this is I mean I just
fundamentally disagree you know this is
the same JP Morgan that forecast that
you know we would fall into a recession
in the last two courses of last year in
it is supposed experts in the city have
been woefully wrong over the last 12 15
months I think they continue to be wrong
and they should be ignored frankly you
know most countries in the world operate
under WTO rules if it works well for the
United States for Australia for China if
it's good enough for them it's good
enough for us we shouldn't be worried
about that at all it's different it's a
perfectly acceptable base case I love
mine is I'm just going to let you
respond to that but let's hear what
Theresa May said first of all about a
transitional deal it is in no one's
interests for there to be a cliff edge
for business or a threat to stability as
we change from our existing relationship
to a new partnership with the EU by this
I do not mean that we will seek some
form of unlimited transitional status in
which we find ourselves stuck forever in
some kind of permanent political
purgatory that would not be good for
Britain but nor do I believe it will be
instead I want us to have reached an
agreement about our future partnership
by the time the two-year article 50
process has concluded from that point
onwards we believed a phased process of
implementation in which both Britain and
the EU institutions and member states
prefer prepare for the new arrangements
that will exist between us will be in
our mutual self-interest so do you
believe that phased implementation is
practical I think it's almost certainly
necessary I understand why Exeter's are
nervous about this because they think
it's keeping one foot in but I think in
a practical sense it's going to be very
difficult Ian because one of the things
which tourism it didn't really refer to
is that the the stance of Michel Barnier
in negotiation will be article 50 it's
about negotiating the terms of exit the
interesting here Richards view about
Drazen main are saying we're going to
have to make continued contributions
there could be worth quite large capital
sums though that will be the focus of
negotiations and Barney's initial stance
will be I'm not willing to negotiate
anything after exit until exit has been
agreed and ratified I go back a moment
earlier to your conversation about JP
Morgan and WTO I don't think word not
credible is sense but it it can work
what is not credible is the prime
minister talking about some associate
status of the customs union and also
accepting WTO terms you can't have both
so that is a slight cake and eat it but
compare without the earlier cake Sanitas
this is a much more qualified issue
we've narrowed it down okay Richard that
is a point resume conceded in her speech
didn't she that we are going to have to
carry on paying into the EU in some
shape or form I mean that is something
that you said wouldn't happen if we
voted to leave no actually actually if
you examine what she said she said that
if we want to continue to be part of
certain programs in and around the
European Union then it's reasonable to
consider contributing towards that
that's a very sensible friendly way of
saying we want to continue with certain
arrangements that work for us it may be
a Rasmus it may be horizon
20 20 whatever so that's a sensible way
of approaching it and and you know we
should welcome that you know she set out
a very firm but friendly tone from which
to start the agreements and in terms of
Michel Barney on his point about article
15 the negotiations what he's suggesting
is illegal under article 8 they have a
legal obligation to negotiate the new
arrangements with us during this two
year period so he's completely wrong
Richard how much is an acceptable some
for the UK to be paying into the EU
after brexit well then that could come
out in the round of the negotiation
we'll see how it shapes shapes up you
know the Prime Minister and her
negotiating team will look at it in the
round and I'm confident based on
everything we've heard so far that she
will come up with a sensible arrangement
but if she doesn't then she's been
absolutely clear and we should have no
worries no deal is better than a bad
deal one though deal is better than a
bad deal is two years enough time to get
any sort of deal a tip at all well I
don't I don't think it is and I'm being
quite straightforward about that I'm I
fully accept we're going to leave the
was a remainder but I accept that the
decision has been taken and all credit
to the Prime Minister she's not making
any excuses he's not saying this it's
going to be harder than you thought it
was so now it's on her and her ministers
to deliver to this timetable and to this
outcome I think there are still
significant issues at the there's that
there are large payments that will have
to be made to exit and that these could
be several billion pounds which which
we've not really cheered an address
article 8 Richard doesn't refer to
negotiations between an EU and EU
country so article 50 is the only one
that matters here in article 50 is quite
clear it's about exit and I've dealt
with Michel Barnier I've negotiated with
him in the past he's a difficult lighter
and he will he will he'll play it hot
he'll also play hard the whole issue of
EU citizens being here mean they've been
left hostage by Theresa May she said
nothing about the right of continued
residence of existing UK a EU people in
the UK or
need our people in EU countries so there
are a lot of things that their body is
going to use to negotiate with us on
okay well Richard refer to the no deal
is better than a bad deal let's hear
what treason may have to say on that
while I am sure a positive agreement can
be reached I am equally clear that no
deal for Britain is better than a bad
deal for Britain because we would still
be able to trade with Europe we would
still be free to strike trade deals
across the world and we would have the
freedom to set the competitive tax rates
and embrace the policies that would
attract the world's best companies and
biggest investors to Britain and if we
were excluded from accessing the single
market we will be free to change the
basis of Britain's economic model Sir
Richard tice Theresa May's effectively
threatening to turn the UK into
Singapore on steroids if the EU doesn't
give us a deal that we can work with is
it it's not very wise I think you be
honest we should be aiming for that
anyway regardless of whether or not we
have a deal you know it's a huge
opportunity singapore on steroids sounds
pretty good to me and if you if you
lower tax rates then growth will be
higher and therefore you'll create more
jobs and more revenues for the
government to spend on public services
so we should be looking forward to that
anywhere I would be delighted if the
Chancellor would say that we're going to
move towards a 15-percent corporation
tax rate